and we'll see how many people are out
there
watching us or listening to us
as we hopefully go live
yep okay we are live
on the into the impossible podcast
Network joined by a very special guest
it's not it's not so often you get a
guest who's who's a friend who's a
fellow experimentalist who's an
inspirational person to me personally
and someone who rejected me and didn't
take our offer to come to be a professor
at UCSD that hurts uh we will uh we will
have to get over it but it's Professor
ianavishik who's a professor UC Davis
you know how are you doing today
I'm good wow calling me out so I'm a
long time viewer of your pods so happy
to be here yeah it's great and I hope to
hope to get in person again I think well
one of the last times I saw you and I
was at your wedding but the other time
was at MIT when you took me around uh
and gave me a tour there it's so so
gracious of you and I hope to visit you
up at UC Davis if they'll have one of us
Southern California types up there but
you're an expert experimentalist and you
do research into the physics of
superconductivity along with a large
team of researchers uh you've written
many many papers and
and uh this is sort of partially uh well
I should say this it's way more in your
ballpark I'm getting emails and texts
from my brother from uh David David
Friedberg who's a big time billionaire
investor the one of the besties on the
all-in podcast he's asking me what do
you think what do you think and I'm
getting uh you know hints of people like
which should I start shorting Nvidia
stock you know is this the end of
semiconductors the stakes are really
high as you know you know this could
really transform the world I made just a
small list as a hook to the listeners
and the viewers out here and I want you
to add your own as well
but um we're going to put up a link to
your to some of your tweets that have
been really helpful to me and knowing
how to assess these counter claims and
claims and we may be lucky enough to be
joined by pass gas Jorge Hirsch down
here who who
um is not so sanguine that this is a
real effect and I think we'll be back uh
with him later on I'll put a link to our
previous chat earlier this year the
these uh reports of room temperature
superconductivity are coming faster and
more Furious than you know the Padres
hopes are being dashed at getting into
the playoffs but here's just some of the
things that I've been thinking about uh
that high temperature room temperature
ambient pressure superconductors could
give to us and I want you to add your
own and pick your favorite energy
transmission uh zero resistance
transmission could revolutionize power
transmission making it more efficient
reducing global warming effects that's a
certain benefit of a ambient temperature
and pressure superconductor
Transportation levitating trains we've
all seen that and that will be key in
what we get into with the meissner
effect which you know you've forgotten
more about most of the stuff Ina then
I'll ever know Healthcare we had uh
recently had an MRI and we used none of
those oh Professor hers is joining us
let me add them in
uh Jorge is in the Green Room Jorge can
you hear me
I don't hear you Jorge you're muted
yeah
Maui are you
can you hear me
okay I don't hear you now but I heard
you a second ago you're muted again
can you hear me now now I do now I do
welcome Professor Jorge Hirsch pass
guest on the end to the impossible
podcast uh and we're joined with Ina
bishek do you know each other
uh we have met yes hi Ina hi
um I don't say to you yet but I hear you
uh you may not be able to see each other
but where the audience can see you and
that's uh and that's the most important
thing of all and we will be taking
questions from the audience because
I try to use another browser and see if
we can do this no it's it's fine Jorge
it's it's the audience sees you and and
Eno can I'll do it I'll do a sketch of
what of what Jorge looks like
um
great thank you for joining us we're
talking about all the potential
technological breakthroughs that could
be enabled from Healthcare to energy
transportation to
um uh to to the power grid and reducing
global warming quantum computers I'm
also getting asked questions about you
know is this going to impact the uh the
stocks of semiconductor manufacturers
who's a bestie along with my friend
David Friedberg past guest who's very
interested in your thoughts in this and
and mine are less knowledgeable than
yours let me first start with um with
Ena as an experimentalist how did these
results strike you we've all been let
down before uh and we've all been
accustomed to this kind of dream kind of
dissipating but um how did it first
strike you what were the first things
you wanted to know about this sample and
I guess what should we call it LK 99 is
that the is that what you cool kids okay
our copper uh dope LED app is
or more
technical but
yeah so I'm happy to hear that you're
also a fan of the all in pod
um I listened to it on my uh commutes I
love it
um yeah so
um my first uh
response or my first reaction was no uh
the reason being that
um if you're in this field
um there are these so-called
unidentified superconducting objects
like new claimed high temperature room
temperature superconductors that pop up
reliably uh every uh every year or so so
you know you kind of build up a thick
skin to be a critical uh about them
um but I guess uh reading more into it
uh the upshot is uh and we can go into
more details why uh I think this is the
case it's probably not a room
temperature superconductor wow
uh my uh my feeling about it uh has sort
of evolved into
a cautious curiosity so that's not the
same same as cautious optimism but
I do think that there might be something
interesting there and I am cautious
because curiosity still requires uh
mental resources and and time
um I guess as far as the potential
impact on the world
um that's another place to be to be
cautious so what I can say definitively
is that Material Science and materials
physics and materials chemistry has had
a tremendous impact on the world uh
throughout human history and especially
uh in the 20th and 21st century and it
will continue to do so
um whether that impact will come from
room temperature superconductivity or
other Innovations in that research area
I think uh the other uh Innovations are
more likely so I think at this point we
probably do not have a room temperature
super connector we might have one in the
future there's nothing that's strictly
prohibits it but uh what Nature has
shown us so far is that
superconductivity shows up in many
different materials uh so uh when a room
when slash if a room temperature
superconductor does show up
um we don't know what properties uh it
will have so among super connectors we
know some of them can sustain a large
current some cannot some really expel
all their magnetic field others have a
lot of Trapped flux some are ductile and
can be used to make wires others not so
much some have good native oxides which
is important for making devices for
Quantum Computing and some do not some
are made of Earth abundant materials uh
and can really you know be uh be
deployed world Wyatt and others are not
and so on and so forth so without
knowing material it's hard to potential
impact
so Jorge are you able to hear us now I
can't hear you can you okay yes now now
I do and yeah you don't need to call
back in if you don't see yourself it's
just because I'm focusing on Ina or
myself as I often like to do
um so Jorge uh you and I talked back a
couple months back on the announcement
of the previous uh you know claim of a
room temperature superconductor now when
I ask you when you heard these claims
they're quite different than the types
that we talked about back in February
March around the time of the aps March
meeting uh when all hell broke loose in
this group by ranga Diaz and all this is
a totally new group
um apparently been working on this for
at least uh 24 years maybe more and uh
it has a lot of people convinced that
it's not only room temperature ambient
pressure but it's been replicated in
fact it's being replicated online on
Twitch and other and other venues that
I'll I'll display uh Jorge how did this
result shock you and uh what do you make
of it what's your immediate take to it
well that's uh
that's interesting question the answer
is
um
as I told you by email when I first saw
the preprints an archive and even the
video that they first posted I said this
is not right this is not
superconductivity the the graphs look
really crappy the the resistance drops
Like a Rock it's not what
superconductors do the theory arguments
they give make absolutely no sense to me
so this is
not right and in fact the first video
was totally consistent with
this just being magnetic ferromagnetic
which you would be able to kind of
put it at an angle like that by just a
repulsion of the same poles of the map
and so I was totally convinced this was
an interesting and surprised people were
paying so much attention now I actually
changed my mind
I actually when I saw the the second
video that the Chinese group posted
ER then it it is very clear from that
video that this is not super magnetic so
this is
clearly either diamagnetism or
superconductivity
I don't think there is any question
that's a very tiny particle
that does show this this property that
it repels magnetic fields no matter what
is the polarity okay superconductors do
that and diamagnets like graphite also
do that but it's much much weaker okay
so uh
I then you know changed my mind as I
said and I'm very open to the
possibility that this is real even
though
uh now what does it mean it's real it
means that they have a you know
10 regions of it that may in fact be
super conducting now
there is an inherent competition between
lattice stability and superconductivity
so it's very possible that this
particular structure is very unstable so
it can only be stabilized within small
regions of a larger sample and
and so it's a very open question in my
mind whether this will ever be like a
bug
superconductor that can be useful for
anything
but I certainly do not discount and I
think there's a very strong possibility
that there is
traces of superconducting materials in
these samples that are doing these
remarkable things and if it would okay
let me just add one thing I would like
to say for the hydrides
I was always very convinced that they
are not superconducting and certain rang
ideas work I think it's clearly not
right that's because they relied on
Light Elements which I do not believe
have anything to do with conductivity
this is different this is doesn't have
Light Elements
yeah I guess oxygen is not very heavy
but most of it is lead and copper and
so in my view of superconductivity this
material could well be a superconductor
because it's somehow similar to The
Copper oxide materials in particular it
has anions Like Oxygen minus minus or
even phosphorus minus minus minus would
be in there and those could potentially
be given you
so I'm very open to
believe this may be right wow that's a
huge change and uh very very uh high
integrity to admit that you could be you
know kind of uh led to be persuaded that
this might be real I've known you as a
cautious you know as an optimistic
pessimist but uh but this is I should
say the most optimistic I've heard you
about such materials I ask Ina you know
what if this is partial you know kind of
it's super conducting I happen to have a
sample I smuggled it out of Korea last
night
um no I didn't this is just a meteorite
which you can get when you go to my
website briancating.com but um
especially.edu addresses students and so
forth
um but let's say this is a
superconductor and uh but only part of
it is maybe it's like almost like a
one-dimensional you know Vortex or La
would that change the magnitude of this
discovery let's say we could only get it
in a very compromised state it wouldn't
be you know super conducting for Miles
like niobium titanium we use it in every
application in our lab what would that
mean if it's just kind of a almost like
a topological Singularity within a bulk
material would that cross your hopes or
dreams or how would that affect you
the large chunk you got me there sorry
so
um the the scenario you describe is
actually
um something that that happens quite a
bit in the in the discovery of new
superconductors or has uh historically
um so I haven't been a synthesis person
since uh uh since my undergrad days
um but the the general story is you know
when people are looking for new
superconductors the first result is
often uh something a phase in pure uh
specimen so you have like a little
pocket that is superconducting and the
rest is not super connecting uh and then
you uh maybe you see a blip in the
resistivity doesn't go all the way to
zero or a blip in the magnetic
susceptibility suggesting a little bit
of of expulsion magnetic field and then
uh the people that are experts in this
they find ways to uh single out which uh
which minority component is uh is
actually super connecting and make more
of it so if that is what's going on
that's kind of a uh a tried and true uh
uh path to getting a larger scale uh
super nectar so we have the brightest
audience in the known universe uh here
is a question immediately from uh
someone by the name of Slam RN which I
was going to call my second child as you
guys know uh the South Korean team
claimed that a compound of lead copper
phosphorus and oxygen is a superconduct
or a temperature above 400 Kelvin and
ambient pressure was that a did that
raise your attention at all Jorge I mean
now it's not just a not just a
superconductor an ambient now it's super
conducting when it's on fire uh what do
you how do you react to this question by
slam RN yeah I do not have a problem
with the critical temperature being
280 Kelvin or 300 Kelvin or 400 Kelvin I
mean we're talking about
factors of less than two and I mean the
cooperates are superconducting at 150
Cal and once we know that's possible
then I am not you know I mean I believe
that superconductivity originates from
delicate balance that involves very
strong forces coulomb interactions and
so some small change in that balance can
easily
change temperatures by a lot now it is
true that there is a lot of competition
with other things and with that is
stability as I said and so on but no the
the fact that it's 400 Kelvin 300 Kelvin
does not uh
um and Ena my friend memes of
Destruction which is also my daughter's
name uh he asked um would it make sense
to search for other compounds by
replacing similar atoms in the periodic
table column namely copper atoms with
silver
Etc uh thank you guys he's adding uh
what if you replaced it with other
elements in the same column of the
periodic table would that bear fruit in
a certain sense
um I mean if if that's how you want to
spend your time then
um uh I mean in uh in historical
searches and optimizations of
superconductors there were some elements
of serendipity there were some elements
of like deep chemist intuition built up
over uh decades
um I would say the uh the first order of
business would be to uh try to replicate
the the present results and also
um just uh
be very clear about what they show and
what they uh do not uh show like for
example a characteristic of a
superconductor is zero resistance
um in their uh graph of resistance it's
not really zero the y-axis is uh it's
actually uh not a small uh resistivity
so I'm gonna play hopefully I can play
this video here maybe not uh it's not
seeming to be working
um Let me let me get out of this then I
had some animations that I wanted to
show from my friend Richard Bahia Santa
Barbara it works on these materials I'll
put links in it uh when I finally do get
all this set up to broadcast the screen
share
um so how do these compare Jorge with
the with the cup rates or with the you
know the previous record holders I mean
isn't it substantial almost of different
quality to have super connectivity you
know raised almost doubled in
temperature I mean aren't these things
fundamentally different or
is it is it possible that these are just
sort of a perturbation in some materials
face space away from one another
yeah no I I do think that if these are
superconductors which as I said now I'm
inclined to believe they are they are
not
qualitatively different from the
cooperates in the following sense what I
think is essentially in the corporate is
that you have a an insulator in the
parent State and then when you change
one element by another one you're
adopting holes into the copper oxygen
planes in that case and in this case
you're replacing uh you also have oxygen
you have copper you have lead and you're
replacing lead which could be like a
four plus
Iron by copper which is two plus and
that would also dope holes and when you
don't have copper it's an insulator
and when you do the replacement it does
these things which suggests conductivity
so I uh I do think it's entirely
possible that it is kind of the same
physics that's going on wow okay I think
I might have gotten this to work on the
animation do you guys see this animation
in a
on the screen
maybe it's not working
um maybe that's uh just because it's not
sharing oh no it's showing up on screen
Okay cool so on screen I'm illustrating
this is a Richard B Hill uh friend on um
uh Santa Barbara's got his own YouTube
channel where he's showing you know the
kind of cynical none of a superconductor
which is this resistance dropping versus
temperature and uh starts off and uh
there's a phenomenon where it drops
below what's called a critical
temperature which is not a Delta
function or a step function there's
linear resistance as you cool it down uh
then dropping to uh zero resistance when
it's in the superconducting state over
some small range in temperature uh Jorge
when we talked last time you had me
convinced about DS is superconductor
that um that it was uh I don't want to
say kind of uh fraudulent or
misrepresented but the the fact was that
that the that the magnetic
susceptibility was really that was the
Hallmark and I want you to talk about
that but before you do I want Ina just
to clarify could this just be very very
small resistance and just not possible
to measure the you know difference even
in a four wire measurement can you nerd
out a little bit for my brilliant
audience could this not just be very low
resistance I mean is it truly convincing
that it's zero resistance
um so
um let me let me clarify uh what I uh
said a little bit so the uh
um
uh these papers are intriguing but
they're uh
um sometimes they have uh issues with uh
the y-axis
um so
um we try to bring up the paper I'm
gonna try to bring up the paper too you
know is there a figure that I should
look at figure five or something oh yeah
figure five okay okay so yeah go on I'll
try to get this up
okay
um I'll I'm looking at it uh myself and
I probably won't be able to see your
screen uh but in any case the y-axis of
resistivity is 10 to the minus 2 uh ohm
centimeters so uh typically uh for
Metals we measure resistivity in micro
ohm centimeters so this scale is about
four orders of magnitude uh larger than
uh we would uh customarily do so in the
uh so-called normal State I guess above
100 Celsius
um this resistance is gigantic it's uh
orders a magnitude larger than kind of
uh a a
a limit that is typically seen in a lot
of of metals I mean not not in all
materials but
um that is a very large normal State
resistance and then if you uh go to
where the resistance kind of plateaus
um they drew a red uh Guide to the eye
and if you trace that to the the right
hand y-axis you can see that it is uh
not quite at zero it's like a little bit
uh above that uh zero line and it's also
drawn a little bit optimistically
through the lowest uh temperature uh
data so
I see okay so yeah I think I have the
wrong paper the one I'm looking at is
this oops
is called what is it called here
uh it's first room temperature ambient
pressure superconductor by Lee Kim and
Quan
the one with the the more authors
what's its name showing levitation at
room temperature and atmospheric
pressure and mechanism okay
so I'll try to get that up but Jorge
um talk about the uh magnetization and
that phenomena we'll get into the
meissner effect in a minute but what
about the magnetization and why couldn't
it be a diamagnet I mean you know the
Eno pointed out like most of us are
diamagnetic right yeah
add to the resistance the comments of
Fina I mean it is true that it doesn't
show the resistance and it looks very
weird and I I totally agree when I first
saw that graphite it wasn't convinced at
all but as I say sometimes samples are
in homogeneous and you know uh it can it
can be the
there is not a continuous path it won't
go to zero resistance even though they
are super competitive now going to
susceptibility you asked me about
the rang ideas situation and there it
was a combination of things
that made me believe that that wasn't
real and so the story there as I told
you last time is I asked for the
underlying raw data because there had
been some subtraction of two different
measurements made and so
the authors kind of didn't want to share
the rotate and that was a big red flag
and so when they finally
share the raw data the it was clear that
the data had been manipulated and
fabricated but from the graphs
themselves you know you couldn't say for
a fact this is not superconductivity or
this is superconductivity so
you know uh you look at the whole
picture but the point is
superconductivity is a very unique
phenomenon okay either is there or it's
not it's macroscopic quantum physics at
work okay so there's no such thing as
very small resistance okay if it's a
super computer it's a superconductor and
the resistance if you have homogeneous
or sufficiently connected sample is
exactly zero and you put in a super
current and they will be there next year
when you come back so it's a
qualitatively different state of matter
okay so as I say you know when you look
at the totality of evidence so far it's
uh conflicting but you know there is
something like the levitation that I
think is very hard to explain and I do
not think that
normal diamagnetism it's true you know a
lot of things are there magnetic but not
with
the necessary strength to explain
particularly the first video that only
showed partial levitation it looks like
a quite
thick sample that with normal
diamagnetism of lead or graphite even
you wouldn't get
you could obtain it right I see you
leave now Brian so what's that I will
have to go now okay well all right thank
you very much uh it's it's wonderful to
get your uh your impression of this I
really appreciate your time and and
hopefully we can do another uh interview
with Lena uh together in person uh with
you that'd be great thanks Jorge thank
you bye good to hear you again Jorge hi
okay so Ena it's the two of us now let's
uh let me just get his offer there
remove from the switcher there we go
okay so
um I got the paper up and I was looking
at the red line that you were talking
about
um you know one of the things that's
always interesting to me is when
somebody comes up with some you know
novel claim which is of course wonderful
but then it also they come up with an
explanation you know for an alternative
effect in other words they solve a
problem
um or they point out a problem in the
existing model or Paradigm then they uh
then they reinvent it or come up with a
new invention and I'm thinking about
people in cosmology that
say want to reject the Big Bang or or
you know confirm some other model of
theirs and they come up with the new
model we just have to live stream with
Allison Kirkpatrick of Kansas University
Kansas about this very issue we're a
scientist in Canada you know claims that
the web telescope results are not
consistent with the age of the universe
in fact he comes up with the universe
that's 26 billion years old twice as big
and that's always kind of interesting
not only point out a problem and an
existing Theory but but you know come
with a new Theory what do you make of
this that the theoretical results are I
heard and I tweeted to you you know for
confirmation because you're my thread
girl you know now there's too many
thread boys out there so that there's a
thread girl now everyone should follow
inovichik at on Twitter and elsewhere
when I tweeted like what is this really
confirming I mean it's a theoretical
simulation but um but I should say again
reminding the viewers we you are not
convinced Jorge is convinced it's
actually the opposite of what I expected
um so you're not convinced this is
superconducting and that's that's
wonderful to to hear the strong opinions
but tell me what would convince you what
would you like to see besides raw data
and a huge sample and I'll I'll sell you
this one if you let me you know babysit
your kids or something I don't know uh
tell me Ina are you babysit my kids how
about that
um so tell me what what would convince
you or what would make this more
plausible is it the simulations is that
was that adding to believability
um
so
there's uh I guess uh believability or
uh verification it's uh it's not a
singular thing
um it is a process and I think and the
process will continue I think beyond the
the current uh hype cycle
um so I I want to see uh replication
um and uh it should be noted that
replication will take time and if it's
not replicatable that'll take time like
uh if your students do something for a
week I don't think you'll allow them to
claim success or failure uh as uh I will
not either so um it'll take a
time even though in the paper they lay
out the the synthesis procedure but from
anecdote when you follow the procedure
in a different lab in a different
location
oftentimes uh you need to make
modifications this happens all the time
when people move to another University
in another climate another humidity uh
believe it or not even though uh the the
synthesis procedure might be rigorous it
does uh need to be kind of modified uh
in a new environment sometimes uh yeah
so I'm just waiting for uh for
replication uh for uh I guess more uh
uh different types of measurements uh
maybe so
um I am like I said uh um uh uh
cautiously curious that something
interesting might be uh going on and in
particular one of the ways that this
material sort of quacks like a duck uh
is that uh it's uh diamagnetic response
how it uh magnetizes opposite to the
applied field it does have uh some
dependence on if it's cooled in a
magnetic field versus not cooled in a
magnetic field so
um I'd be curious to see other types of
measurements in a in a magnetic field
like uh even the the crystal structure
or something like that
and talk about this the simulation that
you know I kind of asked you about the
other day on Twitter at least they claim
it lbnl using superconductor uh to
obtain a confirmation of superconducting
Pathways when you replace
um you know Atomic substitution uh what
goes into such simulations although
you're not a simulator perhaps
um yourself you must be familiar with
the both outcomes and also the potential
systematic effects of such simulations
so what did you make of those
simulations and and how should a lay
person like me in this field uh apprise
themselves of what to believe based on
those simulations
um yeah so I guess uh I'm like you said
I'm not an expert in these uh either you
should ask uh Sinead uh Griffin to be uh
a guest
um but
um what I will say is that these sorts
of uh calculations are uh pretty
standard and let me just back up and say
uh what was uh posted so uh the the
calculation was not directly uh
something to do with is this material
superconducting how does it superconduct
why does that super induct what was
calculated was something called the
electronic band structure which it tells
you how electrons move around in a
material in the normal State when it's
not uh super connecting
so
um to uh there's sort of these are these
are pretty standard uh calculations
um however there are uh in this system I
believe some approximations uh that need
to be made uh given the fact that it you
have some of the lead being replaced by
copper you have sort of a non-stoigy
metric as it's called compounds so uh
some approximations uh have to be made
there
um so the results of these electronic
structure calculations uh was uh
something that is currently a very Hot
Topic in uh condensed matter physics and
what was reported was a flat uh band so
what that means in more uh common speak
is that the electrons in this material
uh in in the way that it was simulated
are predicted to move uh much uh slower
than expected so that means that the
kinetic energy of electrons is is small
and there's another energy scale
associated with with electrons in in a
material and that is the fact that
they're charged particles and they have
coulomb repulsion uh amongst themselves
so every electron repels every other
electron a lot of the time amazingly we
can just ignore it because the kinetic
energy is so large but in this case uh
we cannot so uh having a flat band does
not tell you that you have a
superconductor or that you necessarily
have a propensity towards a
superconductor what it tells you uh what
we do know is in flat bands you get a
lot of interesting things kind of
reliably happening sometimes you get
superconductivity sometimes you get
exotic type of magnetism sometimes you
get the charges arranging themselves in
weird ways so it just is a fruitful
platform for uh surprises and materials
okay great
um so we have a bunch more questions
from the audience uh what would what's
the current status of replication if you
if you're aware of it uh more more than
I am perhaps
uh so there have been a number of of
papers uh posted on the the archive and
maybe more as we're having this
conversation
um so
um I I don't want to comment uh too
deeply uh because I haven't read them
but uh what what I can say is that
replication attempts are underway and
um I can also say that you should not
expect a definitive answer in such a
short uh time period because in
experimental research uh if you start
doing something uh today you that you
haven't been doing for years uh prior
you're not going to probably reach the
conclusion in one week all right uh one
of my listeners or viewers T is asking
if it's not a superconductor but instead
has a tremendous humongous diamagnetic
constant could that still have
technological uses
for example uh uh magnetic levitation it
relies on on on on this uh effect so so
potentially uh just uh having a very
good diet magnet could have uh uses
and then we didn't get to really share
your personal kind of uh thoughts about
the technological implications or the
cultural implications this is like the
you know discovery of the transistor I
mean if it's true let's just say it's
true which you're currently and I think
rightfully so still skeptical waiting
for more replication data evidence from
accredited individuals uh backing from
from laboratory from Theory backing Etc
um but I should say sometimes that
doesn't occur I mean Jorge has told me
that he's not really uh that persuaded
by BCS theory is the correct description
and of adequately describing the Meisner
effect which I should show you on the
screen because Richard the heel put so
much beautiful effort into it I'll put
that up in just a second but anyway talk
to me about
um you know the technological
implications and cultural or yeah how
will it affect you admittedly we're both
nerds but how would it affect the world
potentially
um yeah so
um uh I guess
first of all in bringing up Jorge's
thoughts you bring up an important point
that uh we can have a superconductor uh
without understanding why it becomes
super conducting without understanding
the mechanism and we can still you know
go through the process of engineering it
optimizing it to carry more current
optimizing it to be more face pure and
so on and so forth so a lot of progress
can be made without understanding as has
been the case with the copper oxide high
temperature superconductors which at
present day are the highest transition
temperature at ambient pressure uh
confirmed
um but yeah as far as uh as technology
um I think
um when you have a material that changes
the world uh no matter what its
properties are that that change the
world uh it's it's sometimes hard to
predict the applications in such uh an
early stage so some of the things you
described are some of the things that we
know how to do with superconductors we
know how to transmit a large current
with them we know how to uh how to make
a large electromagnet uh with them but
uh as an example of what I'm saying
let's let's go back uh
uh a hundred years to the low
temperature superconductors uh that were
uh discovered uh and then 50 years or 40
years later they were uh understood
there was a theory that many people
accept about why they become uh
superconducting and then another 40
years later in the 90s people had the
idea hey uh we can use these for Quantum
Computing and that is a new application
that kind of uh took off uh I guess uh
90 years after the uh initial discovery
of the the superconductor so
um I think uh the the real applications
maybe we can't even uh Envision them uh
the ones that we can Envision them maybe
it will not be so cost effective right
so I have a couple more uh questions
from the audience in the last 10 minutes
or so just reminder subscribe to the
channel leave a like if you want to see
more episodes like this with friends of
mine like Ina Jorge and other
cosmologists we're going to have a deep
dive with my former professor at Brown
University Robert brandenburger who's
presenting a new description of the
early Universe called string gas
cosmology which does away with inflation
using string theory and we went into a
very very deep dive on perturbation
Theory and all sorts of cosmological fun
facts of an interview with Richard Ellis
who wrote a book over here about
galaxies in the cosmos from an observer
perspective
and we have interviews with Dave Farina
AKA Professor Dave and
um and also upcoming ones with Gad sad
and other luminaries so uh it's quite an
exciting summer for the into the
impossible podcast especially joined at
short notice by my friend and
inspiration inovichik professor at UC
Davis
um and so uh you know I want to show the
magnetic levitating effect which is also
goes by the Meisner effect is this just
like a parlor trick is this something
that you know you really think about on
a daily basis is like oh if it had zero
resistance then it was um you know had
this first order fair whatever second
order phase transition whatever it has
um I won't believe it until I actually
see that it has the Meisner effect is
this is this just a parlor trick or is
this something that we should all demand
of all of our superconductors
um are you are you talking about seeing
a video Yeah well yeah I mean or just
whatever it does does that have to be
can you imagine a superconductor that's
real legitimate Etc that doesn't exhibit
them eisenary effect or is this a
requirement of a superconductor
so I guess there
there's there's
a so-called type three uh super
connector but but generally you get
Meister effect it's one of the defining
features of a superconductor uh as far
as like seeing it
um uh like in pictures or videos that's
that's cute
um but I guess what researchers really
care about is uh is a quantity called uh
magnetic susceptibility so it basically
you have a specimen you apply a magnetic
field a known magnetic field and you
measure how much uh that material gets
magnetized and then you divide the two
and it gives you the susceptibility
which as the name implies tells you how
susceptible is the material to to
getting uh magnetized by an applied
field uh so in a superconductor uh what
the signature is is you have a negative
susceptibility so you apply a magnetic
field it gets magnetized uh opposite and
the uh the the size of this effect uh
tends to be much larger than in ordinary
uh an ordinary diamagnets like uh like
us uh like hydrogen uh like uh uh
beryllium there's a lot of the periodic
table is is diamagnetic it's it's very
uh common but how superconductors differ
is that it tends to be larger uh and
also uh there tends to be uh some uh so
uh
so it tends to be larger in a
superconductor and one defining uh
attribute of a superconductor that
differs for example from a perfect
conductor is so if you have a perfect
conductor which doesn't exist in real
life but uh you know a hypothetical uh
object and it is in a magnetic field uh
and the the flux lines penetrate your
perfect conductor you uh you cool it
down uh the flux lines will stay so it
will not do a perfect conductor doesn't
care if uh when you cool it uh in a
magnetic field a superconductor if you
cool it in a magnetic field this is
called field cooling uh at the critical
temperature TC when it becomes a
superconductor it will expel uh some or
all of that magnetic field so you'll get
an onset uh of that uh right at TC and
uh people that are experts expensive
measurements can look at uh at sort of
the difference in susceptibility between
when you cool a magnetic field and you
cool in zero magnetic field and make
statements about you know how
superconducting is this what's the
shielding fraction all the stuff that is
not my precise expertise I say okay
great so now I'm going to show so I've
been showing the just a magnetic field
uh expulsion courtesy of Rich B Hills
um wonderful animations and you're going
to be seeing more of those we have a
video that I made about about the oligo
implementation as a dark matter detector
so we're throwing everything together
aliens superconductors and dark matter
detection
um so now I'm going to show his video
that he made of a so this one it shows a
normal a normal uh sort of a
superconductor suspended in a magnetic
field by a wire and then you know in the
gravitational field and for a normal
metal that that metal does not expel the
field so it goes straight through it and
then I showed on the superconductivity
is Manifest as the temperature drops on
the right below the critical temperature
TC that the flux lines get expelled now
I'm going to cut the supporting wire and
we're going to show the behavior when
you have a normal metal or the
superconductors in its normal State then
it's going to be levitated by magnetic
field and then we're going to turn it
off by and taking it above its critical
temperature so you'll be able to see
this when you watch the replay and uh
and so forth but here we go on the
Meisner effect part two and this is
called Falling magnetic field okay so
now it's a superconductor the
temperature is going up it goes above
its critical temperature normal behavior
sets in and the block of normal material
then drops down and falls down and we've
seen it's there were several you know
pictures and videos of this and even a
little speck of it uh from a from a
replicated apparently replicated sample
which was uh which was kind of cool to
see as well okay so there's
um there's a couple more questions in
the last few minutes that Ina is gracing
us with her presence and that one comes
from
Lambda cool last name hopefully I'm not
butchering your first name and that is
why does superconducting energy check
charge associated with Magnetic
permeability and superconductive
materials I guess maybe
um why is the magnetic properties of an
electrical zero zero resistance Electro
conductor why is that so relevant why do
people care about that Aina
uh why do they care about uh uh the
expulsion of magnetic field well yeah
why are the magnetic properties relevant
for I mean don't you only care about you
know the fact that has zero resistance
that's going to lead to all the
breakthroughs right I mean the
levitating trains sure that's that's
cool but uh but the the zero resistance
defeating global warming everything is
that not going to come from its
electrical lack of resistance
um well
um uh as you know there's a there's a
core uh Topic in physics called
electricity and magnetism so the two
phenomena do tend to go uh hand in hand
um I will say in the context of
superconductivity uh research when you
have a new proposed superconductor
um uh there's there's bad reasons
something might have zero resistance
maybe your wire shorted as you know it
has uh probably happened in in some uh
reports uh but when you have the onset
of another effect at the same
temperature that kind of gives uh more
uh credibility to the result
um especially if that other effect is is
a signature of the phenomenon so
generally
um in this field of research in
condensed matter physics uh we like to
see lots of things happening to really
uh make us more sure that that we're
that we're seeing uh something real and
in a super enacting transition a lot of
uh things things happen and there's an
opportunity for many different
experiments to uh lend uh credibility
okay someone named temp which is uh
appropriate I guess says hey why are you
both completely deflecting to mention
the two replication successes from two
Chinese universities in China rushing to
take credit for South Korea's Discovery
Well as you know uh you know I love to
wade into culture wars and so no I I
we're not deflecting it we're not paid
by uh by China or anything like that
Tampa I don't I didn't see your question
but um anything to comment on the
replication I mean you did mention it
already I don't think there's much to
add right you know
um uh yeah I'm not talking about it
because I haven't uh uh read it and uh
this is just because things are coming
in uh so fast so yes replication
attempts are good and uh we'll see how
it plays out in the coming months
okay my friend Ernesto is asking are
there implications for telescopes so we
use superconductors all the time for our
belometers that we use for the CMB uh
cosmicro background detection uh but
they're they're quite um they're quite
sensitive as they are getting to you
know another type of superconductor
would be interesting but not perhaps as
interesting as some of the other
Technologies like microwave kinetic
inductance detectors Etc
um let's see what else we have here any
other questions
um so let's see capability doubles so
um yeah levitation seems to be on
everybody's mind especially with regard
to you know UFO disclosure and stuff
I've got a lot of interesting characters
uh that that do like this and actually
I'm on an email thread with Brian
Josephson and uh and many other UFO
aficionados and I did just do an
interview with Ryan Graves recently that
you can find on my channel on the F-18
pilots who uh claims to have uh
witnessed data to to some uh Events off
the coast of the Eastern United States
anyway any uh any thoughts about
advanced technology maybe not of this
Earth Ina could could we say anything
about that uh in the remaining minutes
that this could be you know the the next
great leap for for Humanity to on our
Voyage to become interplanetary
so uh no but I guess you do have a
colleague that potentially saw
signatures of maybe minute super
connectivity and extraterrestrial rocks
so
um it's yeah that's the connection I
have
all right so uh yeah there's just a lot
of really fun questions about the future
and you know warp drives and yeah can we
use the flux tubes to you know take us
back and teleport us back in time I'm
gonna take the opportunity the last two
minutes that we have together the thank
you so much Ina
um and refer people to follow Ina on uh
Twitter at inavishik and I'll put a link
to that in the show notes I'll put your
website in there as well but Ian as you
know is a long time listener I always
like to ask deep existential questions
and I want to ask you too one of which
is inspired by Arthur C Clarke I guess
they're both inspired by Arthur Clark
I'm honored to be the associate director
of the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination at UC San Diego
and the first one would be the quote
that we open all of our podcasts with
which is in Arthur's voice
where he says any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable for
Magic
and I I don't know have you seen the
movie 2001 A Space Odyssey no okay yeah
you're too young uh but anyway it's a
famous iconic movie but one of the parts
starts out did you see the Barbie movie
no you didn't see the Barbie movie come
on don't tell me you saw Oppenheimer
please I'm I'm at home watching uh
Netflix with the littles
well uh when you come visit me we'll
we'll all go out we'll take our girls
out to see Barbie and Opera I saw up an
odyssey bar but Barbie apparently opens
up with the scene that these evocative
of 2001 A Space Odyssey where these
monkeys or primates are hitting this
tablet with a bone they don't really
know what it is and then they flip the
bone goes up in the air and it and the
girls and Barbie are hitting Barbie
dolls and so forth as I understand it
I'm going to be doing a video of the
physics of Barbie soon stay tuned no I'm
not gonna do it but um but the scene
really comes from 2001 A Space Odyssey
where they're you know they find this
monolith and the monolith we don't know
what it is the Time Capsule is a
sentinel is it a watch or a lurk or what
is it but I want to ask you in this way
um what piece of technology to you is
most or least distinguishable from Magic
what is the most impressive technology
as an experimental physicist that you've
ever encountered maybe not in your own
work what's the most impressive thing
that human beings have ever done
wow
um
that uh I have to admit I haven't really
uh
um
thought of that
I mean
it's it's hard to answer because
um technology is is just uh everywhere
and
um
I don't I mean I I would say that our uh
our computers our uh silicon-based uh
electronics
um it's strange for me to to say this
because it's uh it's sort of related to
my field very closely how
um all the components uh uh work but
um the fact that you have so many
transistors in such a small uh uh area
and so many steps in the the fabrication
process and then it's uh subjected to
all kinds of environments as you know
you uh have it in your pocket and drive
it around in a hot car and whatnot uh
take it through an x-ray machine at the
airport whatever and uh it still works
uh so that is really uh remarkable uh
when you you think of it and the the uh
capabilities sort of continue to uh
increase we have not hit the the end of
of of Moore's Law yet and I think this
really illustrates
um just how uh Central and almost
magical Material Science and material
physics is
um in our uh everyday uh world and I'm
really happy that with uh LK 99 people
are sort of appreciating one corner of
of this field yeah absolutely yeah to
find people debating on Twitter you know
is it type two is it type one and yeah
uh it's pretty it's pretty thrilling
when the alternative is you know
debating uh some indictment of a former
president or something like that
um okay you know last last question as
as you know we have a lot of uh very
brilliant technical minded guests and
also audience members many of them are
men although not all uh there's a good
number that are female and I'm I'm proud
that not only have I had on you know
some of the greatest luminaries but also
people that are relatively lesser known
both male and female
um of all different you know Creeds and
races and colors but I want to ask you
in the form of the inspiration of the
title of this podcast which comes from
Arthur C Clarke's another saying of his
which is the only way to determine the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible that's where I
got the name of the podcast I'll ask you
in the form of advice to your younger
self you could include your experiences
as a woman in a male-dominated field or
not I don't it's up to you but I want to
give yourself advice you have 30 seconds
to talk to your 22 year old self up at
Stanford graduate student or or what
have you
um I want to ask I want to ask you to to
kind of let me know what would you tell
that person to give them the courage to
do as you've done to go into the
impossible
um okay so I um uh many uh young people
uh like uh I was uh as well or sometimes
uh uh
too courageous uh in in a sense like uh
they can be uh Reckless uh sometimes
um so I'm not sure if courage is the the
limiting uh Factor um but uh I guess uh
the advice I would give to my uh younger
self is uh is to to work harder so in
those
um early days uh when uh you know you
don't have other responsibilities
um that's really the the time to set the
foundation for uh your future uh uh
career and
um also do not throw away your old uh
problem sets and exams
they maybe they may come in handy when
you have to make your own problem sets
and exams as a professor well Professor
inovichik uh distinguished colleague of
mine at the University of California
system the greatest University
on the face of the Earth
um can't wait till we can get our
families together and hang out it's been
too long and I wish you all the best
thank you for taking our listeners on
this deep dive into the physics behind
the headlines and helping to explain and
break down where we go from here and I
just want to I wish you a great rest of
your summer and uh like I said gotta
take the kids to see the physics of
barberheimer
absolutely thanks for having me uh and
thank you for for you know Having the
courage to delve into this thing that I
know is far uh outside your everyday uh
interests it is thank you Ena it's been
great
so uh thanks everybody I hope you
enjoyed this episode deep dive into
physics no we don't only talk about uh
aliens on this podcast uh though you
know as you guys are noting there are
many different possibilities that
technology could be Advanced
substantially if we were to somehow make
contact in the future
but I will continue to discuss the
breaking news and science there are
claims of so-called dark stars being
observed by my friend uh Katie Freeze at
the University of Texas at Austin and
she's been a guest in the podcast before
and she and her team claim that they
might have detected what are known as
dark stars which may provide new
glimpses into dark matter I'm going to
try to get her back on the podcast and
take a couple days off enjoy the summer
now that it's finally gotten clear here
in San Diego and spend some time with
the family I urge you all to do that as
well and there's going to be a huge huge
breaking news on this podcast at least
with upcoming appearances by Yours Truly
on uh some really foundational podcast
shows I've already sort of started to
leak out some of that information if
you're on my magic Monday mailing list
because any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic I have a mailing list where I
share the latest and greatest in
technology and science and things I'm
doing and for those of you with an edu
email address you're automatically
guaranteed to win a meteorite maybe not
this size this is the one that I tricked
Ina so cruelly into thinking it was a
sample of LK 99 I wonder if that's more
expensive than what I pay for these
meteorites but anyway if you go to
briankating.com list slash list you'll
win uh get a chance to win on one of the
next hundred meteorites that I do send
out but if you go to dot edu or if you
go to briancating.com edu meaning that
you have an edu address either your
professor student postdoc what have you
go to this link right here you'll win a
meteorite for sure because my mission is
to guarant you know kind of gather and
synthesize a cohort of all of you the
greatest Minds on the earth and kind of
help guide you through the process of
either high schoolers going into college
college students becoming better at
their research and Scholastic Endeavors
and then graduate students post-docs
faculty Etc because I think the future
you know of our Humanity depends on this
and I think it's great for people like
musk and others to say oh we have to
become interplanetary but we have a lot
of issues we can solve here on Earth but
only if we have a really astute educated
area diet listening audience and and
educated populace so I'm trying to
connect a million Minds in my Multiverse
of minds and part of the way I do that
is communicate through my mailing list
brianking.com
so please do go to that and uh and we'll
keep in touch and stay tuned for as I
said some huge appearances
um uh at least two or three of the
biggest uh kind of uh podcast venues out
there in the world besides this one
where the brightest Minds in the
universe gather so I hope you like it
hope you'll share it uh the Channel's
really grown a lot uh start of the year
with about 79 000. subscribers on
YouTube and we've almost doubled that
and uh hopefully we'll double more and
double more and exponentially and
increase until the whole planet is a
member of this magical Multiverse that
I'm blessed to be uh be partnering with
you on so enjoy the day send me
suggestions follow on Twitter and
Instagram Dr Brian Keating YouTube Dr
Brian Keating and send me some
suggestions for people we had a deep
dive into the claim of this uh very aged
hori old Universe 26 billion year old
Universe I did hear from the author uh
Professor Gupta at
Ottawa and he agreed with a lot of the
things we presented and we might have
him on so let me know what do you want
me to investigate uh these news items we
can do a weekly news update we can do
more deep Dives more solo episodes check
out my physics of uh of Oppenheimer
video which has received uh is coming up
on uh well a great many views so I'm
pretty proud to of that video and um and
then hopefully you'll uh you'll enjoy
and share share the the podcast with
your friends and family that are
interested in science and doing deep
Dives I never dumb things down I never
ever want to be accused of of doing that
so we have these great animations thank
you Richard uh bahil uh from Santa
Barbara these were such a treat to have
these let me know if you like these
animations if you want to see more we're
going to have a video about the physics
behind ligo which is a gravitational
wave Observatory but Richard has been
working on some magical animations of
how it can be used as a dark matter
detector combining some of the greatest
um unknown mysteries in all of science
so for now your fearful host Dr Brian
Keating from the University of
California San Diego and the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination
thanking you for spending so much of
your time with me and imploring you to
stay tuned tuned and hit that
notification Bell because you're not
going to miss some of the upcoming
podcasts interviews deep Dives and some
appearances by Yours Truly on other
people's podcasts signing off Brian
Kitty